merci président alors j'ai écouté
attentivement vos interventions
messieurs messieurs dames et alors vous
avez parlé de la Guyane je suis
sénatrice de la Guyane et vous êtes des
chercheurs et je compte sur vous parce
que nous avons mis un dispositif de 100
% contrôle à l'aéroport et malgré ça les
mules continuent que faut-il faire c'est
vraiment ce fléo s'amplifie en Guyane et
franchement les élus attendent beaucoup
d'ailleurs sur cette ion d'enquête
sénatoriale pour obtenir vous parlez de
coopération internationale oui oui mais
ça n'empêche pas que chez nous c'est
c'est c'est les parents n'en peuvent
plus les élus n'en peuvent plus la
police n'en peut plus il faut qu'on
trouve une solution même si l'objectif
de cette commission justement est de
proposer des moyens mais je compte sur
vous parce que franchement là les les je
ne cesse d'être interpellé par les
citoyens en disant parce que ce sont les
enfants des enfants et pas forcément de
class se défavoriser ce sont aussi des
enfants des jeunes maintenant ça va
juste aux malades qui partent en
évacuation sanitaire c'est grave même
s'il un malaise social mais il faut
qu'on arrive à à à arrêter ce ce ce flux
de de de de de déplacement de enfin de
transport de de de de cocaïne c'est pas
possible on en peut plus en Guyane alors
messieurs dames je compte sur vous vous
êtes des chercheurs moi je n'ai pas la
solution j'aurais bien aimé même s'il y
a eu des dispositifs qui ont été mis sur
les arrêtés enfin une expérimentation
préfectorale mais ça marche pas ils
savent qu'il y a le contrôle mais ils
viennent quand même on refoule 50
passagers mais bah il y en a qui sont
passés ça c'est clair donc voilà on ne
n'est pas trafiquant on le devient par
définition et et et donc quelles sont
les les conditions d'émergence justement
de de ce trafic donc on peut dire qu'il
y a des phénomènes Pol comme on dire en
anglais des phénomènes pou pool ça c'est
c'est c'est aussi les gros trafiquants
qui savent utiliser les plus jeunes dans
l'organisation parce que ils sont
malléables parce que on on va les
sélectionner et phénomène pouche c'est
aussi parce que ces jeunes sont attirés
par par les lumières du du du du
prétendu gain facile sur la Guyane
effectivement on y est allé avec David
on a bien vu je laisserai plus peut-être
répondre sur sur cette question
simplement de dire là aussi il y a un
tissu associatif qui est très dynamique
et qui permet de travailler avec les les
zones justement du côté de Saint-Laurent
du Maroni avec les différentes
populations c'est avec soit les
bchinengé ou les Amerindiens il y a il y
a vraiment un gros travail mais
effectivement c'est peut-être pas la
hauteur de
l'enjeu et et pour répondre à votre
question c'est vrai qu' il y a eu cette
on on a vu le le le glissement depuis le
Surinam jusqu'en Guyane avec cette ce
dispositif qui a été mis en place
notamment à chipol dispositif de d'un
scanner un scanner très puissant qui a
qui a qui a a déporté ou reporté le
trafic pardon vers vers la Guyane pour
moi la Guyane c'est comme je l'ai dit
c'est la tête de pont française face au
narcotrafic de la cocaïne c'est une
problématique régionale Naser à
justement parler du Surinam on pourrait
parler du Brésil hein qui est la
première porte de sortie de la cocaïne
du continent sud-américain je pense
qu'on est quand même sur un schéma
régional j'ai pour exemple une enquête
journalistique auquel j'avais très
modestement contribué qui suivait
parcours d'un passeur vénézuulien qui
depuis Caracas savait qu'il y avait des
départs à Cayenne avait été dans un
bureau de recrutement à Caracas donc il
avait été recruté par des groupes
criminels régionalisés il était parti à
Manaos au Brésil rejoindre une légion
d'autres passeurs qui étit après
dissiminé dans l'ensemble des ports des
aéroports pour partir donc on voit bien
qu'on est sur des chéats
régionalisés extrêmement structuré avec
des groupes criminels très puissants qui
comme la dit Nasser recrutent à foison
chez les jeunes en des errances qui ont
peu d'argent et cetera